The cell cycle is a control system that
creates two accurate copies, or
daughter cells, from each mother cell.
For cells to replicate and stay more or
less the same size, they have to double
in mass before they divide. To keep the
same genetic material, the DNA must be
copied too. The cell cycle is divided
into four phases called G1, S, G2, and
M. During G1, or Gap 1 phase, cells
accumulate biomass until they are
almost double their original size.
Cells then commit to START. START
involves the activation of a central
regulatory protein called cyclin
dependent kinase, or CDK, in an
irreversible positive feedback loop.
Now cells enter S, or synthesis phase.
CDK turns on thousands of protein
machines that make new DNA and rapidly
churn out a copy of the genome. Once S
phase is done, cells may pause again in
G2, or Gap 2 phase, to create more
biomass or correct any errors that
happened when copying the DNA. Once
everything is ready, M phase, or
mitosis, ensues. The chromosomes
condense and are captured by the
mitotic spindle, which is a machine
that pulls them to opposite ends of the
cell. Finally, the cell divides between
the two duplicated genomes, creating
two daughters that are very similar to
their mother, but not always exactly,
each with an identical copy of the
genome and half of the cell's contents.
A final note-- there are surveillance
systems, or checkpoints, in place in
case something goes wrong. If DNA
copying doesn't complete on time or if
DNA damage occurs, then the DNA damage
checkpoint can delay the onset of
metaphase. Furthermore, if the
chromosomes are not correctly attached
to the spindle, the process of
chromosome division is also delayed.
Completing the cell cycle correctly is
crucial for our bodies to live and grow.